[Applause]
yeah yeah we're back we're
back you missed us didn't you it's
Friday so you know what that means let's
welcome tonight's guest Sherwin Williams
named their whitest paint after him Fox
News contributor Tom
shaloo he has gun permits for his arms
and construction permits for his legs
Fox News contributor Johnny Joey
[Applause]
Jones win in doubt she'll deep fry it
out co-host of the bottom line of Fox
Business ful business what's happening
to me denan
McDow and every Halloween adults come to
his door and give him candy New York
Times bestselling author comedian former
NWA world champion
taus all right all right all right all
right before we get to some news stories
let's do
this great RS leftovers my leg all
right it's leftovers where I read the
jokes that we didn't use this week and
there were a lot and as always it's my
first time reading these so if they suck
we'll take out Joe Mackey's teeth one by
one with a pair of Rusty
pliers he likes
it all right a new study says sexual
satisfaction may be key to delaying the
onset of
dementia so yeah better get on that Dr
Jill
[Laughter]
disgusting you're disgusting President
Biden has officially condemned Hamas
saying he prefers salsa or guac with his
Peta bread and
chips the Australian version of Maxim
magazine is placed Daniel ladley a
biological man at number 92 on its list
of 100 hottest women no comment yet from
number
[Laughter]
93 Gary chandling
rip researchers have found that certain
species of female frogs will lay
completely still and play dead to fend
off potential mates huh too bad that
never worked with my
uncle
e you like to have sex with frog
all
right not better that made it worse that
made it worse all
right who knew a former Girl Scout
Treasurer in Delaware was arrested for
allegedly stealing
$122,000 the treasurer may have gotten
away with it for so long because none of
the Girl Scouts could do
math a sexist would say I agree that's a
terrible joke Joe Macky just lost a
tooth Joe Biden said the alleged rocket
attack on a Gaza hospital was quote done
by the other team incredulous reporters
wondered why is he blaming
homosexuals analysts say customers are
rejecting Disney's new woke image even
at their theme parks apparently they
drew the line at Tinkerbell's
penis
Bell's penis ruin that for me don't ruin
that for me reports earlier this weekend
confirmed that Disney Inked a big deal
with China's Tick Tock it's Disney's
worst pairing since Sleeping Beauty
replaced Prince Charming with Bill
Cosby I know an easy jet flight was
cancelled because a passenger took a
dump on the bathroom floor what do they
think this is Air Force
One what
wow you love a good
joke now while passengers said the smell
was very offensive The Travelers on
their way back to San Francisco didn't
seem to
mind new reports are claiming that this
year's heaviest pumpkin could make up to
over 700
pies 700 pies you
ask a recent Mouse study revealed a link
between dementia and inhaling Menthol
although the mice did report they were
alive with
[Laughter]
pleasure do you think they used white
mice Tyrus probably
not New York mayor Eric Adams has
returned from his trip to Mexico where
he met with potential migrants warning
that if they aren't careful they could
end up in New
York president Biden has a new ad
assuring voters he's not too old to run
again he's also claiming that his
Jamaican caregiver is stealing from
him thanks to a public fundraising Drive
the world's first vagina Museum will
reopen next month in London apparently
it was closed for 5 days last
month
yeah there were a lot of ways to go with
that joke and we that was the cleanest
one according to a new study ice cream
and potato chips are as addictive as
cocaine and heroin and you can trust the
results of the study because it was
conducted by
experts a liveaction version of the
Animated Series gargoyles is in the
works and you'll never guess who's been
cast to play the lead
roles one two and finally according to a
recent study 49% of people in serious
relationships think about someone else
during sex and you'll never guess who
that someone
[Applause]
is all
right let's do some news this week we
saw the media get duped by another hoax
and this time what a Monumental up on
Tuesday a rocket fired by near-sighted
Jew haters hit a hospital in Gaza of
course Hamas blamed Israel and claimed
500 people had been killed obvious lies
but it still was hand delivered by the
Hamas PR department our mainstream media
who ran with it like Carl Lewis with a
missile up his ass they got the
story completely wrong because they took
the word of terrorists and like
accepting a parcel from Ted kazinski it
blew up in their faces damn it ran on
the New York Times front page and there
was an AP headline that ran quote Hamas
run Health Ministry says Israeli air
strike on Hospital killed hundreds and
are all Pals at CNN tag the news from
the Palestinian Health Ministry Reuters
cited Gaza Health authorities in other
words Hamas but you think the media
would have learned a lesson after being
duped hoax after hoax the Covington kids
smette the Bubba Wallace news the P tape
Russian collusion saying Hunter's laptop
was Russian
disinfo but they can't stop why is that
because they're told what they wanted to
hear by the people they wanted to
believe they already knew who the good
guys and bad guys were whether it's
Jesse Hamas or BLM in the Universal
filter of Oppression they are the
oppressed and you are the oppressor and
if cities go up in Flames blame the Jews
so are they admitting that they screwed
up not a chance because doing so means
the people that they really hate namely
us were right about something and they
can't have that meanwhile our commander
and padded briefs instead of focusing
solely on Israel linked it to Ukraine
I know these conflicts can seem far away
and it's natural to ask why does this
matter to America so let me share with
you why making sure Israel and Ukraine
succeed is vital for America's national
security you know history has taught us
that when terrorists don't pay a price
for their Terror when dictators don't
pay a price for their aggression they
cause more chaos and death and more
destruction if we walk away from Ukraine
if we turn our backs on Israel it's just
not worth it all right so why this
arranged marriage between a fresh
tragedy and a dragged out War that's not
Clarity far from it the trick is if
you're against Aid to Ukraine well then
you hurt Israel but there's something
gross about using a terrible event as
part of a package deal it reduces its
horror and its meaning what a wasted
opportunity to bring Clarity to an event
by saying what no one else will say that
we are dealing in the Here and Now not
history that goes back centuries this is
why the passion of of co-eds is so
laughable for it's truly amazing that
someone born in 2005 has the solution to
a problem that's vexed Humanity since
Biden was sniffing the hair of a woolly
mammoth history is often used to justify
present day horror putting the onus on
you to endure long endless scream aons
with ignorant babies and no one screams
louder than today's college students who
warmed up their lungs bitching about
pronouns and bathrooms and the cultural
appropriation of the cafeteria is taco
Tuesdays for the left it's a game with
no end especially when they're getting
paid for
it oh that's right I already introduced
you
guys Tommy yeah happy Friday yes yeah
Greg yeah what would you choose to uh
respond to the media who uh always rush
to believe the bad guy yes and the I I
love what you said about the it reduces
Biden's speech reduced the effectiveness
of both arguments it's like when you
watch an ad on TV and they they don't
stop selling you things and they give
you now how much would you pay but don't
stop there we get you a set of steak
knives and then you know oh that
original product stinks I don't need a
potato peeler you know and so that's
what he's he's doing he's essentially
this is very fresh they uh Hamas just
slaughtered all these Israelis and he
throws it in with you know his last pet
project and it really weakens it it's
terrible and then how many times did he
mention in the US it was like he was
saying uh you know he's like he like I
felt like he couldn't read his
teleprompter you know he's
like he uh he's looking really hard you
know it's like open your eyes maybe
you'll see it yeah but the uh like it's
like he his eyelids are like blinds that
he draws down as he's sleepy G to flip
him up uh but how many times did he
mention the United States you know he
says oh terrorism is terrible we know we
have terrorist here in this country he's
still trying to pound that like Maga as
terrorist thing he throws in all his pet
projects and here I thought it was
totally weak and I mean I think it's
remarkable that you know that I I he got
bad reviews didn't he yes he did yeah he
do there you go all right way to Ender
end weekly well that was his point yes
yeah that's it yeah there you go Joey
how damaging is this sort of
misinformation for the people who are
fighting in this war as a veteran Who
has fought two Wars yeah you know what's
great is if you really want to lose a
war go into it not really wanting to
fight it to begin with mhm that's what
really pisses me off about when he gave
when he gave this speech I think what
what really bothered me most is he
subtly threw in Iran in one sentence and
then almost immediately went to uh went
to he said you know uh Israel is not
responsible for what happened at the
hospital but we have to make sure we
abide by the rules of War you know how
else can you talk out of both sides of
your mouth you know his age in ability
probably like chews and food comes out
both sides of his mouth but in this
point it was you know this
self-righteous IND Nation coming out
both sides of his mouth when you say
something like that and address that
important you're saying nothing less
than hey those of you who are kind of
saying that isra Israel is committing
war crimes man I hear you I hear what
you're saying and I'm going to make sure
they don't this is the sad truth of War
when you go to war you are you are
choosing to commit evil so that evil
can't be committed to you there is
nothing Pure or righteous about war but
there's something righteous about
defending yourself so that the the
innocent people you're responsible for
don't suffer while you're in charge I
would hate to be Benjamin Netanyahu I
would hate to be the president of the
United States because going to war is
the worst thing in the world you could
do but if you're going to go to war MH
go to war to win and the
different the sad
truth babies are going to die either way
MH but do they die because someone from
Hamas attacked them and tried to kill
them or do they die because Israel is
trying to get get rid of Hamas bombs a
facility that has Hamas terrorist in it
and a baby's too close that's the only
difference yeah and to sit here and
parse it out and try to make it into
something that's not I fought two Wars
that we tried not to win because we had
to have clean hands well guess what we
don't have clean hands and we lost them
mhm there you go
D do you uh why don't the why doesn't
the media ever fess up for their
mistakes you're in the media you admit
wrongdoing constantly often on this show
yeah and Tyra yeah if and Tyrus knows
this as a
man if you ever want to get laid again
what do you tell your woman I up yeah if
you ever want to get a keep your job or
you know what if you actually have a
moral core you admit when you're wrong
if you if you want to live with yourself
but these people don't because well one
they're arrogant
and two uh they are Hamas supporters and
their bias betrayed them that's why they
were so quick to jump on this story
because they side with against Israel
the oppressor and they side with the
terrorists because that they view pal
Palestine as the oppressed again that is
actually the colonizer and the colonize
that's all Soviet Union propaganda how
funny is that that they've picked up and
run with over these years but it would
be if you just said it like this I would
be fine with it why would you when they
reported all these stories if they just
came out and said terrorist told us so
that that is the truth telling if they
just said it that way all right Tyrus uh
you want to talk about
Joe or the media well it's all connected
it's all connected it it comes down to
one thing we this nation we have a war
over
accountability because you can say
things and do things without any
accountability you can ruin someone's
life you can make crazy you can argue
you there's no such thing as a woman
anymore because there's no
accountability right and so when they so
when you want to say Hamas is the
Freedom Fighters for Palestine and and
the Jews are horrible monsters that are
doing all these things there's no
consequences it used to be when a
reporter got it wrong he had to drag his
ass on in front of the TV and be like
ladies and gentlemen I reported wrong
and I corre and I have a correction he
had to do it personally or even better
if it was so if it was such a glaring
mistake he was fired so he was gone
nobody was fired for getting it wrong
because getting that story wrong lit a
fire across the world there was the next
day people were trying to burn down
embassies countries were saying get the
hell out of Lebanon because you got it
wrong but we live in this time and this
this young group they can go out and
they can say anything they want to cuz
no consequences what was everybody upset
about not that the kids signed a
petition it was because they're not
going to get jobs now it's not fair no
it's called accountability so as long as
we continue to have this argument we
like well they they they can't they
can't respond Israel can't go in there
and and wipe out because the it's not
the Palestinians fault yeah it's it's
hamas's no it's not hamas's fault it's
their fault so therefore you can't do
anything now we're seeing Israel lives
by a different guide they live by the
accountability if you come into my house
with a stick and hit me with a stick I'm
going to come at you with a gun and they
have every right to do so so this
argument that we're seeing across then
our president comes on I'm just going to
say it listen it was difficult for me so
I understand Mr President but sometimes
sometimes you just got to do it you got
to put the damn glasses on because no
one's afraid of
this there you go all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else